[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: There it is.
Thank you.
I'm Rafael Fernandez
SLAVA CHERNYAK:
I'm Slava Chernyak.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: We
work in Cloud Dataflow,
and we're very excited to
be here today and tell you
a little bit more about what
happened in one of the demos
that you saw this
morning in the keynote.
In particular, the
taxi data Demo.
So we're going to take a
closer look at that one.
We're going to focus on the
continuous event processing
aspect of that demo
using Cloud Dataflow.
We're going to take a closer
look at how you, as a GCP
Developer, can compose
various services that we have
on the platform so
that you can enable
all the various complimentary
data processing patterns
that modern
applications require.
We will also spend
some time highlighting
a very powerful feature in the
Cloud Dataflow service, which
allows you to update your
continuous computations
in real time.
The services that we're going
to be talking about today
are Cloud Pub/Sub, Cloud
Dataflow and BigQuery.
They are all fully managed,
they're all scalable,
and the do different things.
Cloud Pub/Sub is our Pub/Sub
publish and subscribe service.
It's global, it guarantees
at least once delivery.
Cloud Dataflow is our fully
managed data processing service
that will allow
you to run programs
that evaluate your data either
in batch or streaming mode.
It comes with a very
powerful programming model,
which is the result of years
of focusing on the developer
experience at Google--
we think you're going like it.
And what this
programming model does
is it allows you to stay at
a higher level of abstraction
describing your data
transformations,
instead of going down to
the distributed systems
level and all those intricacies.
Last, BigQuery is
our fully managed
petabyte scale, low cost
data warehouse for analytics.
It's a favorite
for data analysts.
So what we want to
do here is we want
to use a live stream
of telemetry data
that is coming from taxis
in the New York City area,
and we want to build a series
of data paths for this data.
We're going to process
it, and we're going
to power different experiences.
One of those experiences
could be a live visualization
of this data as it is occurring
on the New York Metro area.
As you can imagine we're going
to be relying on Cloud Pub/Sub
to deliver these
messages, and it probably
wouldn't be a wise choice to
bill this application directly
in the client.
Wouldn't be a bad choice
because your client,
if you have a single
machine that's
in charge of
displaying this data
and doing all
these computations,
you're going to end up up
with an experience that
looks a lot like this.
Basically, an ever-growing
queue of undelivered messages.
That's probably not what
you want in a lively map,
or in a lively display.
You will continue to
process this data,
but the results
that you're getting
are not lively-- you're
actually falling behind.
So this suggests that we
need, for this portion
of our processing, a
different strategy.
There are also likely to be
other requirements in addition
to liveliness,
because you're dealing
with data that, at the end
of the day, results in money.
So correctness, completeness,
reliability, scalability,
and performance are
kind of built in when
you process your data here.
We need to honor those.
We also have this
requirement of liveliness
which suggests continuous
event processing,
and another thing that
we're going to be doing
is we're going to be archiving
the data as it comes along,
with some transformations,
for further use.
Since we have systems that
allow us to store data
at a very good
economical rate we
can just be archiving
everything we
see for analysts to
later study and mine
and derive some more insights,
in addition to the ones
that you are doing live.
Another thing that's common
in this type of activities
is being mindful of your
Application cc Management--
how do you coordinate updates,
how do you patch things.
So we're going to be talking a
little bit about that as well.
Let's start with one
concrete example.
Let's count right.
So Slava, take it away.
SLAVA CHERNYAK: Thanks, Rafael.
So let's talk about what we'd
like to do with our taxi data.
Our taxi telemetry is
arriving and it's already
said that we'd like to condense
it into something that we
can process on a single
machine in our visualizer.
We would like to use
Dataflow to write
a Pipeline to do this for us.
time That would take raw taxi
telemetry and transform it
into something condensed
in time and space,
but we'd like to do
this in a way that
preserves enough information
for our visualization
to still be accurate.
We're going to step through
and talk about how we do this.
So the raw taxi telemetry data
would look something like this.
You know, we have latitude
and longitude points,
we have time stamps about the
most recent location of a taxi,
and we'll have some
other additional metadata
such as how many
people are in the taxi
or what the current
taxi meter reading is.
So how do we go about condensing
this data in time and space?
Well, first we're going to
Window the data in time.
What I mean by this is that
we are going to group together
all points that
occurred sufficiently
close to each other in time.
So all points for the
interval one to two--
that's three points here
get grouped together--
and all the points that
occurred in the interval
from two to three--
that's one point
here get grouped together.
The next thing we'd like to do
is group the points together
in space.
Again, what we do here
is we assign groupings
based on the location.
So XY points within a Window
get grouped together--
that's two points.
KM points within a Window
get grouped together--
that's one point for
the one-to-two Window
and one point for the
two-to-three Window.
Finally what we
do is we count up
the points in each such
time and space grouping
and we ready to
emit the results.
That's two taxis for our x and
y in the one-to-two interval,
one taxi for km in the
one-to-two interval,
and one taxi for km in
the two-to-three interval.
So what have we actually
accomplished here?
Well we've described a set
of logical transformations
that take us from
our input data--
our raw taxi
telemetry-- and give us
something that is much
condensed in terms
of the volume of the
stream, but still carries
sufficient information to be
correct for our visualization.
OK, how do we take this
logical description
and actually turn this
into Dataflow code?
Well, we do it like this.
Notice that every line of
code here corresponds exactly
to a logical transformation
that we described over our data.
We've encoded the set
of transformations
that move us from the
raw taxi telemetry
into a condensed
volume results stream.
Also important, this
is real Dataflow code
and notably absent from
this code are things
like setting up clusters,
spinning up virtual machines,
deploying resources, recovering
from crashes or faults.
All of these things are being
handled for you by Dataflow.
So what are Dataflow programs?
Dataflow programs describe
logical transformations
over collections of data.
These collections are called
PCollections and maybe bounded
or unbounded in the
case of data streams.
The transformations
are called PTransforms,
and they may be executed
over these PCollections
to produce new PCollections.
Together these
allow us to build up
a Pipeline which describes
how our data is transformed
from the input to
the desired result.
So look at this Pipeline.
We start with a PCollection
which we read in from Pub/Sub.
And this is an
unbounded PCollection,
which means that that data is
continuing to arrive forever.
We then apply a
sequence of PTransforms
to it, creating new collections,
PCollections, at every point.
And the resulting PCollection
is written back out to Pub/Sub.
The Pipeline continues to run
forever until it is stopped,
because this output
PCollection is also unbounded.
There we go.
So we use Transforms such as
Windowing, Mapping, and Count
here.
These are built into
the Dataflow SDK
and you had to do
no additional work
to use these other than just
invoking them in your code.
Other transforms such as
CombinedRides or CondensedRides
here can be written by you.
So I'm going to show this
CondensedRide transform here,
which you wrote and then applied
in parallel over the data,
which basically what it does
is it just groups together
points that occurred within
100 meters of each other.
And so this is being run
in parallel over your data
in a streaming fashion here.
So once we have
written our Pipeline,
what do we do with it?
Well we can run it on
Google Cloud Dataflow,
and we tell it some basic things
like where to read the input,
where to write the
output, some parameters
like the initial number of
workers we want it to use,
and then we run it.
And what's happening
when we actually run it?
Well lots of things
are being taken
care of by the back end for us.
It's optimizing
the execution graph
so that execution
happens more efficiently,
it's spinning up VMs,
it's staging Pipeline code
to those VMs, it's managing
the I/O with Pub/Sub,
it's managing persistent
state for fault tolerance.
And by the way, let's talk
about fault tolerance.
If the VM happened to crash
or any other kind of fault
happens, the Dataflow
execution engine
will transparently
restart things for you
and continue to
work, and no data
will be lost because
of the check-pointing
of persistent state about
the Pipeline execution.
So Dataflow
guarantees are always
preserved even in the case of
machine crashes, exceptions,
anything else.
So once this Pipeline is run
here's what it looks like.
This is just a
snapshot of the UI.
Andrea did a talk
earlier today where
she went very much
in depth in the UI,
but this is just a snapshot
of what this looks like.
This gives you a little bit more
information about the Pipeline.
It tells you about the
Pipeline as a whole,
it tells you about the
steps, it tells you
how many workers are
processing, how many messages
are being consumed by
each step in the Pipeline.
And by the way, if you
notice, this Pipeline
looks a lot like the logical
diagram that we drew earlier.
So your Pipeline-centric view
about the transformations
that you're performing in your
data is maintained in this UI.
So I want to call your
attention to one thing
here specifically,
which is that if you
can read that over there
the volume of the stream
fell from about 20,000
messages per second.
After we condensed
in time and space
it fell to about 2000
messages per second--
a tenfold reduction, which
is the desired outcome.
So now we can point
our visualizer at this,
and we see the same results
but now we can keep up.
We know we can keep up, because
when we look at the Pub/Sub
subscription statistics
in Stack Driver
we see that our
backlog is not growing.
If you notice there's
an initial spike here.
This is when the data
flow was spinning up.
While the workers were coming up
we were building some backlog,
and then when the worker spun
up and started processing
they churned
through that backlog
and then continued to
keep up ever since.
This is one example of a
Dataflow program in action.
I want to talk about a
couple of particular aspects
of the Dataflow programming
API that make it interesting.
Specifically I
want to talk about
how do we deal in Dataflow
with unbounded data.
Our taxi ride data has no bound.
Events continue to come
in forever, so in general
as data gets larger we
may want to break it
up into smaller
chunks for processing.
If we're using a
traditional batch system
we might do something
like daily Windows,
but really this is
just a cheap way
of dealing with data
that is unbounded.
So one of the difficulties
of unbounded data
is that there may be unknown
delays and data may show up out
of order.
Look at this record here.
There's a few records here
that all happened at 8 o'clock.
One occurred and was delivered
to us right away in the stream.
to us a little bit later,
but this green record
that occurred at 8 o'clock
here didn't show up in our
stream until six hours later.
And who knows why that could be.
That could be from a
multitude of reasons.
Maybe a user had an event
occur on their phone,
then they put their
phone in airplane mode
and didn't turn it
back on for six hours.
Maybe a server crashed
and didn't come back
online for six hours.
Maybe there was a
network delay you know,
an undersea cable
got cut somewhere.
Who knows.
The point is that if we're
writing a stream processing
system we need to be able
to deal with such delays.
And depending on
what you're doing
the strategy for dealing with
these delays is also different.
If you're doing some sort of
element wide transformation,
element-wise transformation
maybe you don't care.
If you're processing
an element at a time
and you don't care about
when that element occurred
or the context of that
element, this is probably fine.
But things get a lot
trickier if you're
doing some sort of
grouping or aggregation.
So one obvious strategy is to
use Processing Time Windows.
So you slice up your
stream and processing time,
and what do I mean by that?
Let's say every time
a clock ticks over
by an hour you draw a
boundary in your stream,
and you process what you have.
Well this is easy
to understand, sure,
but this probably doesn't
give you what you want.
If elements are
delayed or out of order
they're probably not going to
wind up in the same processing
time buckets.
So for example are
two messages that
both happened at 8 o'clock.
If your aggregation involves
grouping them together
or reasoning about them
when they occur together
you're going to have
a hard time with that
since they're going to be now
in two different processing time
Windows.
So for example if you're trying
to count taxis that showed up
in the same place
around the same time,
Processing Time Windows are
probably not what you want.
What we'd really like to have
is an Event Time Windowing
Strategy.
As input is arriving.
We want to perform
a Time-Based Shuffle
to place their records into
Windows based on their event
times.
The way to do this in Dataflow
is with the Windowing API.
And so Windowing
allows you to do
is that Windowing allows
you to divide events
into Windows based
on event time so
that you can reason about
them in the correct context.
So Dataflow supports
many kinds of Windows.
A couple of examples, although
by no means an exhaustive list,
is something like Fixed
Windows-- the simplest type.
These are Windows that can
be every minute, every hour,
every day, and so on.
And these Windows are
typically the same
across all processing keys.
Another example that's
similar is Sliding Windows.
These are similar
to Fixed Windows,
but made up of
smaller panes which
allow them to slide with
time moving forward.
An interesting thing here
is that the Windows actually
wind up overlapping.
Another interesting example is
something like Session Windows.
So Sessions are those are
events of activity surrounded
by periods of inactivity.
And so an interesting
thing about Sessions
is that the boundaries
of a Session Window
are functions on
the data itself.
They're not knowable a priori.
So they must be computed as
you're processing on your data,
and will depend completely on
the data and very differently
from key to key.
So this is not something that
is possible or easy to do
with a traditional
batch system, but it
is easy to do with Dataflow.
Other Windows are,
of course, possible
and are a matter
of implementation
and whatever the requirements
of your application are.
So Windows let us answer the
question of where in Event Time
we would like to
perform our aggregation.
We still need to answer a
different question which
is, when in processing time we
are ready to emit our results.
In order to do
that, we first need
to better define the
relationship between event time
and processing time.
So let's look at
this graph here.
On the horizontal axis
we have Event Time,
and on the vertical axis
we have Processing Time.
And every event that happens
that is delivered to our system
and processed by
our system is going
to wind up somewhere
on this graph.
In an ideal world
where events are
delivered to us instantaneously
and processed instantaneously,
every event would line up across
or along this ideal diagonal.
So it would be delivered and
processed at the same event
time, as we process the same
Processing Time as the Event
Time of its occurrence.
Of course reality
is not so nice.
You know there's network
delays, processing
is not instantaneous.
So in fact all of our
events wind up somewhere
above this ideal diagonal.
Dataflow provides
something called
the Watermark, which helps
us reason about completeness.
The Watermark tells us how
far above this diagonal
we can draw a line
beyond which we don't
expect to see any more events.
This Watermark is represented
as a red line on this graph.
If we know everything about
our sources perfectly--
so if we're reading
from a source
that we know everything
perfectly and completely about,
the Watermark is a hard
guarantee, that in our system
we're never see anything
beyond this delay.
Of course in many cases
our knowledge is imperfect,
and so the Watermark is
also an imperfect guarantee.
It's really a
heuristic that tells us
to the best of the
system's knowledge
when do we not expect
to see any new data.
Either way the
Watermark can tell us
when we expect to have all
the data for the given Window,
and therefore when
it is correct,
as far as we know, to the
best of our knowledge,
to emit the results.
So if we look again
at the Windowing
as a Time-Based
shuffle, we can see
how the Watermark helps
us know when to emit
the results of a Window.
However, the Watermark
may not be everything
that you want to use
for triggering output.
There are two major
reasons why you might want
to consider something else.
First of all, the Watermark
may be too slow, so to speak.
The Watermark is trying to be
as conservative as possible.
It's trying to keep
track of every event
in the system, which is
great from the standpoint
of completeness, but
maybe you don't care.
If you're doing daily
Windows, for example,
you're not going
to get your output
until the end of the day
at the very earliest,
but you might want some
speculative early results
earlier.
So the Dataflow triggers
API, allows you to trigger
early speculative output.
The Watermark may
also be too fast.
We already said that if
we don't know everything
about our sources,
meaning our source
can produce late or
out-of-order data,
the Watermark may be imperfect.
And so an event might come
in even after the Watermark
has already advanced.
In this case Dataflow
provides late data triggers
that allow you to handle late
data when it occurs in order
to emit updates to your results.
So let's look at building
this example up a little bit.
Here we have Windows
two minute Windows--
Event Time Windows-- that are
being closed by the Watermark.
So what we're doing
in these Windows
is we're building
a running total.
As processing time
moves forward,
represented as up
in this graph, we
know when we can close the
Window when the Watermark
passes the Window boundary.
Notice though that
there is one event here
that's not included in
any Window, that event
with a value of nine, and
that's because it was late data.
As I described it was an event
that was emitted by a source
after the Watermark
already advanced
because we didn't know something
perfectly about the source.
So maybe it was
an event that came
in from somebody's
phone that was
in airplane mode for six hours.
And so the late data
trigger API in Dataflow
allows you to handle that and
then emit some sort of updated
aggregation.
So let's put all of
this together now
and use it to try and answer
a few questions about our taxi
data that we saw earlier.
Let's start with
a simple question.
At a given point in time how
do the taxi rides from airports
compare to overall taxi
rides across New York?
And we're going to
try and use everything
we learned about Dataflow
to answer that question.
So the first thing that
we're going to do here
is we're going to
write a Pipeline.
What it does here is it
filters out the rides that
originated at airports.
So how do we do this?
Well, first of all, we
read things in from Pub/Sub
as before.
Let's try that again.
The next thing that we do
is we associate the ride ID
with each ride.
So the ride ID tells us which
ride this taxi ride point is
associated with, so that
we can group together
all the points that are
coming in from a single ride.
All right then.
Next we use Session Windows
to draw Window boundaries
around the ride.
So we drop Window
boundaries at the beginning
of the ride, that's
the pickup point,
and 10 minutes after the
drop-off point, which
is the last point in the ride.
The next step in this Pipeline
is triggering, and triggering
controls how results
are delivered
to the subsequent transforms.
Here we trigger continuously
on every element
so that we ensure that
we emit constant updates
to the visualizer.
We'd like to see the ride's
moving along in the visualizer,
so we'd like to see updates.
So we want to make sure
to trigger continuously.
And here we also use
accumulating triggers
as opposed to
discarding triggers
to ensure that we receive
full contents of our Window
on every trigger firing.
We then combine all of
the points in the Window
on each trigger firing.
So we only care, in our combiner
we only care about two things.
We care about the start
point, because we're
going to need the
start point in order
to filter out the rides
that started at an airport.
And we need the
most recent points
so that we can emit that
to the visualization.
The AccumulatePoints combine
function implements this
by keeping track
of the start point
and then updating the most
recent point with the newer one
if it becomes available.
Then we filter by discarding
accumulated rides where
the pickup was
not at an airport,
and we do this by comparing
the latitude and longitude
of the pickup with a well-known
set of latitude and longitude
points for airports JFK,
LaGuardia, and Newark.
Since when we
actually care about
is that the output is
only the most recent point
we use a stage to filter
just the most recent point
from our accumulator.
Finally we write the
results back out to Pub/Sub.
So when we run this,
what does that look like?
So we can see that the rides
visible in the visualizer
are only ones that are starting
at JFK, LaGuardia, and Newark
as desired, and that
the results are still
being updated in
real-time time which
is due to our triggering
condition and our carefully
constructed accumulator.
So the Pipeline we wrote
to filter airport rides
is only part of our
solution however.
Dataflow and GCP make
it easy to compose
multiple independent components.
So far we've talked about
taking the taxi data,
ingesting it via Pub/Sub, and
pointing our visualizer at it.
However, we want to do
more with this data.
So what we do is we actually put
the results back into Pub/Sub,
and then we read them
through an ETL Pipeline,
that I wrote separately,
that takes those results
from Pub/Sub and then
writes them into BigQuery.
This is a very standard
use of Dataflow.
And now we can actually use
that same ETL Pipeline that
writes the BigQuery and
point it at the raw taxi
feed to write the raw data
into a separate set of BigQuery
tables, so we can compare
the BigQuery results
for the raw data versus
the airport data.
So what can we learn?
A simple query
against the raw data
tells us that in a five-minute
interval of time in New York
City there is about
1,700 taxi rides that
drop off somewhere in the
New York greater area.
And the average cost of
a ride is about 14 bucks
and the average net revenue
for the taxi company
is about $25,000 for that
five-minute interval.
How does that compare, for
the same five minute interval,
how does that compare
with the airport data?
Well when we point the same
query at the airport table what
we see is that the
number of rides
is obviously much smaller but
the average-- it's only like 63
rides I think-- but the
average cost of the ride
is much, much higher
as you would expect,
which is about $52 per ride.
There is also a time-based
component to this data as well.
If we graphed this
data over time,
we can see that there is, first
of all, an obvious daily trend
based on time of day in terms of
the overall rides and the taxi
rides, but also there's
some interesting event
happening around just before 9
o'clock here in airport rides.
Maybe there's a bunch of
big flights that landed
or something.
So you can see how you can use
this strategy and these sort
of tools to dive
deeper into your data.
So the next thing that
I would like to do
is I would like to talk
about another cool feature
of Dataflow service.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to deploy new
code to a running
Dataflow Pipeline
live, and we're
going to do this while
keeping all existing
state and aggregations
for the writing
Pipeline while adding
new functionality.
So the code that
we're going to update
is we're going to update
the airport code that I
was showing you before.
We're going to update it from
just looking for rides that
pick up at JFK to
also looking for rides
that pick up at
LaGuardia and Newark.
So first of all, let's see
what it looks like right
now before we update it.
So before we update
it we see that we
have a ton of rides
coming out of JFK,
but not really so much stuff
going on anywhere else.
There are some rides
scattered elsewhere,
but really the traffic
is coming from JFK.
So what we're
going to do here is
we are going to comment
back in the code that
tracks LaGuardia and Newark.
We're going to hit
run here, and we're
going to tell this Pipeline
that it needs to update.
And that's all I need to do.
Because the Pipeline
is named it knows
how to find the old
running Pipeline
and update it with the new code.
So the update is now
running, and that's
going to take a
couple of minutes
and let me actually tab over
to the UI here and show you
the Pipeline will
eventually here
go from a state of running
into a state of updating.
That's going to take
a couple of minutes.
So let's take a look if
it's already updating.
Still staging.
So it's going to start
updating here any second.
While it's starting to update
Rafael is going to talk
to us about-- oh here it goes.
So it's starting to update.
That's going to take just
a couple of minutes here,
and Rafael is going to tell us
about update in the meantime.
Back to the presenter please.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ:
Can you hear me now?
Good.
OK.
So what Slava has
on right now, he
has initiated a live
update of the Pipeline
that is computing our time
aggregates of the data stream.
As you can see he
changed his Java code
and he's deploying this change.
So notice how this is one
piece of our entire strategy
that we've put
together here on GCP.
There is of course,
a direct approach
that you could take to
update this piece of code,
which is bring that Pipeline
down, write a new one,
and resubmit.
That is probably not
the best we can do.
In fact Dataflow can do better.
What would happen
in that use case
if you just simply
bring it down and up,
first of all, Cloud Pub/Sub
will continue receiving events
from all the taxis, all those
events are going to accumulate.
You're going to have some
work to catch up with once
your new Pipeline restarts,
but more importantly, you
will have lost state that was
in-flight while we were running
the original Pipeline.
So why would you
even want to do this?
Why do you want to update?
There's many reasons.
Adding functionality
is one of them,
but another very common
scenario and concern
is what happens when the
libraries that you depend on
need to be version-ed up
for security reasons, right?
What happens when you need to
alter parameters or perhaps
change the type
of machine that's
backing up your Pipelines etc.
So these types of
changes are things
that we want to do with minimal
interruption to the service
and preserving your
intermediate states.
So state is really hard here,
and what do I mean by state?
One of the things
that Dataflow-- hey,
it started working.
One of the things that
Dataflow is doing in order
to guarantee this low
latency delivery of results
is computing things in
an incremental fashion.
So if you focus, for example,
in this count accumulator
near the end, it
really has state
about the Window and the
group that it's seeing
and the count so far.
When the Watermark advances
this particular step,
the system enforces
this particular step
that it is now correct
to emit a result.
So the fact that you've been
computing this incrementally
is what allows you to
emit it right away.
OK?
So you're not going to have to
recompute pieces of the input
when the time passes.
So this intermediate state
is really important to us.
What Dataflow is going
to do is it's basically
going to take care
of that state,
and move to your new Pipeline.
This example probably seems
trivial to you, right?
The Pipeline looks the same, the
state kind of maps one-on-one,
but there are other things that
the service can do for you too
because there are
other changes that we
consider update-compatible.
Examples of
update-compatible changes
that you may want to
enact on your Pipeline
include adding and/or
transforming perhaps
a completely new output path.
That is perfectly legal, that
is perfectly safe to update.
Another thing you may want
to do is rearrange the steps
in your Pipeline.
Perhaps you, because of the
characteristics of your data
and the characteristics
of your code,
through experimentation,
you discover
that rearranging
these steps result
in a semantically
equivalent Pipeline that
happens to perform much faster.
In some cases that occurs.
The order in which you
apply things matter.
Other things you may want to
do is remove steps, right,
like the step that
we just added.
We just remove it.
I put a little star there,
because there is also
a class of updates that
are unsafe to perform.
These updates usually involve
transforms that are producing
or consuming side inputs.
That is, they are away
from the main flow.
They may be using
keyed state, or they
may have some operations
that involve Window merging.
Not to worry.
If you request such a
change the Dataflow service
will reject the
update, but it will not
alter the flow of your
original Pipeline.
So there are other things that
Dataflow is doing here for you.
Once a new job that was updated
from a previous job is spun up
we actually show you the
provenance of which job
it came from and so on.
So this is a lot of work that's
being done on your behalf,
so that you don't have to worry
about all these considerations.
And you can actually
maintain your code even
when it's powering a
continuous computation.
So Slava, what's going
on with our update?
SLAVA CHERNYAK:
Let's take a look.
Demo machine please.
Great.
So we can see that the
Pipeline has been updated.
You can see right here that this
is the same job name running
and it says that it's updated
from the previous job.
And when we look
at our visualizer
now we can see that there
is a bunch of new rides that
are coming from
LaGuardia now, which
is what we would expect after
having updated our Pipeline.
A couple of interesting
things to point out
in this visualization
however, is the fact
that first of all our rides
from JFK are still all there.
We're not just getting
new rides from JFK,
we still have all of
our old rides from JFK.
This is what Rafael
was talking about.
We're preserving the
previous Pipeline state.
Another interesting
thing to point out
is that we actually also
have new and old rides
from LaGuardia, not just
new rides from LaGuardia.
And this is because the
LaGuardia rides were
in the Pipeline
already, we just changed
the code that was filtering
them out at the end.
All of that data was already
in the Windows and in the state
and being accumulated,
we just changed
what we were emitting at
the end of the Pipeline.
So by updating our
Pipeline we started
emitting the full rides that
started at LaGuardia even
before the update ran.
So this is an interesting
thing about keeping
the Pipeline state that really
helps you do the right thing.
In the case of your Pipeline.
Back to slides please.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: Thanks, Slava.
Not shown here is a
ton of work that's
happening behind the scenes.
There are things that
the service, the Dataflow
can do for you such as
automatically increase
or decrease the size
of the worker pool
to better cope with incoming
data spikes and lulls,
because we also scale down.
We save you money,
that's a good thing.
Pub/Sub, not shown here,
but this is a Global Publish
Subscribe service.
It is scalable for you.
It will give you very
interesting guarantees,
so you can build
this type of system
with correctness and
reliability in mind.
And BigQuery, the
analysts' favorite,
completely managed for you.
You have no idea how many
machines are doing what or when
and you shouldn't have to.
You're just writing queries.
This is a really powerful
thing to keep in mind
when you develop on GCP.
You can use Dataflow
to really think
about the rest of the
services of the platform
as either a source on a sink.
You can really be
transforming data
as it arrives for
different purposes,
either for continuous
delivery of results
or for archival or for further
transformation, and really
leverage the very
different services
that we have to enable
the various patterns
that modern
applications require.
So in summary, we just
took a closer look
at some of the technologies
the power of the demos
that you saw this morning.
We took a deep dive on how
continuous event processing
looks like on GCP, in
particular with Dataflow.
You saw a hint of the
programming model.
We think you'll
prefer programming
at that level instead
of programming
at the machine
level, and we're also
emphasizing these best
practices of composition
and really thinking about how
to treat GCP as the platform
that it is so that
you can light up
different things
in a single flow.
And of course with
streaming update
you can now take care of really
complicated lively applications
with minimal downtime
and no data loss, which
we think is very important.
So last I wanted to
talk about Apache Beam.
So in early 2016 we
announced our intention
to move the Dataflow programming
model and SDKs, Java,
and Python we have right now to
the Apache Software Foundation.
I am very happy to share with
you that Apache Beam is now
a top level project in the
Apache Software Foundation.
This is again the result
of us paying attention
to developer
productivity at Google,
developing a new
model that we now
want to have a
community of people
using in a variety of services.
So what's next for you?
If you're interested there
are a couple of talks tomorrow
about Apache Beam.
The first talk is
really centered
about the community
aspect and ecosystem
now that Apache Beam is a top
level project in the Apache
Software Foundation.
You will also find
out how we're going
to move from the
Dataflow SDK to Beam
and what's the
story around that.
The second talk goes a little
deeper talks about Portable
and Parallel Data Processing
using Apache Beam, and what
this portability means now
that this model is really
available for the community.
We have resources for you
as well, a couple URLs there
for you to find more.
There's also a code
lab right here,
if you want to try Dataflow,
you haven't had a chance,
you can actually write a
program here at the conference.
There's another code lab that
utilizes this taxi data, which
is now available to you
as a Public Data Stream,
so that you can play with it.
You can learn how to develop
these type of applications,
and you can access
that code lab at
Codelabs.developer.google.com.
So I want to thank you
very much for coming
and we're happy to
take your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for the talk.
First question is let's say I
had a not a very smart grouping
and I have a lot of
stuff in one group,
and now I run out of
memory in one instance.
What will happen then?
SLAVA CHERNYAK: So
there's a couple
of answers to that question.
First of all, at the
application level you can--
so what you're
talking about is also
called problem of Hot Keys.
There's a couple of different
ways of handling it.
One, is at the application
level you can always
find a better charting strategy,
a better keying strategy
so that you don't
have those Hot Keys.
There's also multilevel
combines in Dataflow
that allow you to essentially
do fan-in to reduce
the volume to a single key.
So it is something
that you as a developer
have to be a little
bit aware of.
It's not something that can
be completely transparently
handled by Dataflow,
because if you
throw all of your traffic
against the one key
at some point there's
nothing we can do.
But as long as you are aware
that that is something that
is happening there are
tools within Dataflow
that make it easy to handle it.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: So the high
order bid for you to keep here
is finding a re-keying
strategy even mid-Pipeline
is a very good way to
guard against these very
Hot Keys or very Hot Groups.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And I had a the second question.
You mentioned basically
these updates that are not
compatible, with
your current system
how would you then
run this update?
So basically, how do I
replace a running system?
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: Right.
So there are several strategies.
In some cases what people
do is they suspend flow.
They know that there
is a computable set
in the case of temporal
Windows of which Windows
are going to be
considered "dirty"
because you will
have lost this data.
So they are prepared
to enact some data
loss, because the upgrade,
it's the equivalent
of a breaking change.
And they are OK in
some circumstances
to evolve their code that way.
Another strategy that we
have seen used successfully
is having different pieces of
one single Pipeline actually
publishing to Pub/Sub using
Pub/Sub as a composition point.
That allows you to isolate
pieces of the Pipeline
that you want to
evolve or perhaps
adding alternative branches
that start to pick up data
after a particular
point, and then
shutting down other pieces.
So that is a strategy to cope
and deal with breaking changes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: OK.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the lateness.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: About what?
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Lateness.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: Lateness.
AUDIENCE: So data that
is out of the Window.
After the data in the Window
has been gotten and accumulated,
if something shows
up out of bounds,
I understand the
default behavior
is to discard that even with
the lateness parameters set.
Is that true?
SLAVA CHERNYAK: Correct, yes.
AUDIENCE: So in the Beam
SDK how would I actually
ensure that, first
of all, how would I
ensure that the data gets
handled and secondly,
does Beam actually
go and pull down
the raw data that was used
to do, like, the raw data
from the original Window?
SLAVA CHERNYAK: So to answer
to your first question,
there is a trigger in
Beam that specifically
allows you to trigger
a processing based
on that late data.
So you do after Watermark
to trigger something
based on the Watermark and
then you would do after,
with allowed lateness, to
add the possible lateness
parameter there.
I'm not sure I understand
your second question
about whether it pulls down
the data-- oh you mean,
does it deliver the
data, the full data
for the original Window
with your late data?
AUDIENCE: Well, does it does
it do reprocessing I guess
is what I'm trying to say.
SLAVA CHERNYAK: So
that's a question
of whether you use accumulating
or discarding panes
if I remember correctly.
So with accumulating
panes every triggering
is going to deliver the
full contents of the Window
whether it's on time or late.
With discarding
panes it's only going
to deliberate the
delta based off
of the most recent
triggering execution.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SLAVA CHERNYAK: Does
that answer you question?
AUDIENCE: Not really.
So the discard actually
just discards all raw data?
SLAVA CHERNYAK: So
discarding, what it means
is every time the trigger
fires we deliver the delta.
We deliver the delta set since
the last triggering firing.
So if you had two triggers,
one triggering at the Watermark
and the second triggering off
the late data, with discarding
panes you would first deliver
the contents of the Window
at the Watermark, and then
deliver just the late data
elements since that's
your only delta.
AUDIENCE: OK
SLAVA CHERNYAK: With
accumulating panes every time
the trigger fires
you would deliver
the entire contents of the
Window, the accumulated
contents.
So at the Watermark it
will be whatever is there.
And at the late
data triggering you
would deliver the previous
contents plus the late date
element.
So whether you use accumulating
or discarding panes
is a function of what
kind of reprocessing
you want to do on that data.
So if you only care
about the late element
you probably want to
use discarding panes.
If you want to reprocess the
whole contents of the Window
you need accumulating panes.
AUDIENCE: And so is there a
time limit on how far back I
can set lateness?
SLAVA CHERNYAK: In practice,
yes, but not at the SDK level.
So in practice how long
you keep your data around
is a function of how
much money you're
willing to pay for
storage, right,
and how much
latency the Pipeline
is able to cope with before it's
no longer able to cope with it,
right?
So as far as I know,
the SDK doesn't
enforce any programmatic
limit on it,
but if you put a year there
and you keep throwing data
into year-long
Windows, at some point
things are going
to start to break.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: And there
are practical ways for you
to evaluate and
experiment how much data
you're willing to hold
on or how much lateness
you're willing to tolerate.
The key thing to
pay attention to
is at what point with the
resources that you have
provisioned at max
do you actually
start to back up in
processing, and you are not
able to keep up anymore.
So you can establish a
bound, a practically bound
based on the
characteristics of your data
on your typical computations
by experimentation.
AUDIENCE: Even though the
Window trigger's fired
processing won't happen until--
I'll catch up offline.
I just--
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: Yeah.
Happy to.
Yeah.
Let's go over here.
AUDIENCE: So I am occasionally
asked to have parameters
that I can configure
on my Pipeline
while it's running
without necessarily
having to do an upgrade.
Is there a good way to
manage runtime configurable
parameters?
SLAVA CHERNYAK: There's a
couple of different answers
to that question.
So one of the answers is
that your Pipeline is always
able to read data
from site inputs
either generated by
the Pipeline itself
or from some other config store.
So if you were to do
that within Dataflow land
you can always
emit a side output
that then is consumed as
a side input somewhere.
And that side input was
actually be a small--
you can think of it as a join of
your data stream with a small,
not frequently mutated data set.
So that not frequently
muted data set
could be your configuration
that if something
were to update there
then you might change how
you're doing your processing.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: This will
not allow you, however,
to change things such as
the length of the Windows
on the fly.
These are parameters
of your own code.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ:
Let's go over here.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question.
For the Watermark, is
it possible to tune in
or to tweak it?
Are there any tools around that?
SLAVA CHERNYAK: So the
answer currently is no.
So what we do when
we try and establish
the Watermark is we
basically take everything
we know about the source.
We try and model the source.
We try and keep track
of all the data there,
and once we get the
data from the source
we then perfectly track
the rest of the messages
throughout the system.
So the goal of the Watermark is
to be as complete as possible
when tracking the data.
So there's no tunable
parameters there.
Can you say more about
what it is that you're
trying to do with it?
AUDIENCE: So I'm concerned.
So it may work in
certain applications,
but it may not work everywhere.
Right?
So does it learn from your data?
Is there a way for it to gather
metrics for a Window of time,
and then set the parameters
or are those fixed?
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: So
I'm not sure I follow.
I think what I hear
you say is two things.
One is you're talking about
the Windowing strategy
and the other one is whether you
can control the passage of time
by basically saying when the
Watermark should advance.
so if you're interested
in the second one
there are techniques
and things that we'll
be happy to talk to you
about that involve triggering
and different things
that you can do.
The Watermark, as Slava
said, is a function
of what the service knows about
the data source, our ability
to examine, you know, your
allowed lateness that you
specify plus what we're
seeing in terms of arrival
and guarantees from
the source, and then we
know when it is safe to
canonically advance time.
SLAVA CHERNYAK: And let
me say one more thing.
Basically, if it is
a custom source that
you're talking about.
If it's a source that you wrote
and you know best about then
you can provide the Watermark
for the service to use.
So you sort of provide the
Watermark for a custom source
and then we use that
combined with the Watermarks
throughout the rest
of the Pipeline.
So obviously if you know best
about what kind of timestamps
your service is providing
you are the best source
for the information on the
Watermark there as well.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: One final
strategy that I will mention.
Again, application
dependent, everything
we've described deals
with logical time, which
means every data event
has time and that time
has meaning and that's
what triggers the Watermark
advancement.
There's also real time, right?
Like where the time advancement
is a function of actual arrival
so where time is not
part of your data
but is really a system
function, there are other things
that you can do there too.
AUDIENCE: So does the Watermark
take into account both those?
SLAVA CHERNYAK: No.
Well so there is the deeper
answer to that question is yes,
because we actually have
two kinds of Watermark,
but when we say
Watermarked we really
talk about big data
watermark, which is
a Watermark on the event time.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All right, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
the presentation.
It was pretty interesting
to see sessions
as kind of one of
the timing strategies
so I would like to ask if
sessions in streaming, I mean
with streaming data, is
possible and if there
are some efficiency glitches
that we should be cognizant of.
SLAVA CHERNYAK: So
the first question
is whether sessions in
streaming is possible.
Yes, absolutely.
I mean, it's built
into the Dataflow SDK.
You can use it right now.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
SLAVA CHERNYAK: Yep.
As far as efficiency
glitches, I mean,
I think it works as intended.
I guess I'd have to ask
more about what the--
AUDIENCE: Event time
versus kind of real time
kind of slips and stuff.
I mean when it
comes to sessions,
because it is something
that triggers by itself?
I mean every message--
SLAVA CHERNYAK: Well so I
mean, sessions, by definition,
is going to have
latency in it, right,
because session
Windows are bounded
by periods of inactivity.
So you won't be able to
know that a session has
ended until you've observed
some time of nothing.
So there is an
inherent latency built
into the definition of session.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: And the
trade-off for the system
to be able to
compute sessions is
going to be space
and resources, right?
So that's really
what's going on there.
If you have very choppy data and
a very challenging sessioning
strategy, likely the
effect is you will
need more intermediate states.
AUDIENCE: Which is
the case, apparently.
I mean, I'm coming from
the advertising industry.
I mean definitely,
[INAUDIBLE] have
to kind of side with
people in sessions in order
to do [INAUDIBLE] on a
micro-scale aggregations.
OK, thanks.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: OK.
SLAVA CHERNYAK: OK.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: All right.
One more question over here.
AUDIENCE: My question
is that what languages
does the SDK currently support?
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: Sure.
The SDK is available
in Java and in Python.
In Python there
are availability--
Sorry.
Python supports
batch in Dataflow.
If you go to the
Apache Beam website
they have a Python SDK
and a Java SDK already,
and you'll be able to hear
more about those tomorrow.
But those are the two languages
that have implemented.
There are also third
party implementations.
Part of this community that
you'll hear more about that
have produced Scala
implementation
of this called Scio.
It's built by Spotify.
And others are starting to be
discussed in the community.
AUDIENCE: Great.
RAFAEL FERNANDEZ: OK.
Well thanks everybody.
Enjoy your festivities.
[MUSIC PLAYING]